et à monsieur frédéric reiss merci
monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse à madame la ministre de
l'éducation nationale madame la ministre
à l'heure du bilan de fans quinquennat
il apparaît clairement que la soi-disant
rire refondation de l'école a débouché
sur des réformes idéologique et
dogmatique qui affaiblissent notre école
le fossé continue à se creuser entre les
meilleurs élèves et les moins bons en
dépit de tous vos efforts de
communication
aujourd'hui nous assistons à un
véritable syndrome de manque de
confiance des familles en vo réforme les
polémiques sur l'école se succèdent
allègrement après celle des rythmes
scolaires une réforme qui reste très
inégalitaire selon les régions
après celle des deux pays une invention
qui volent des heures aux matières
fondamentales
voilà stèle du prédit qu'à de nombreux
enseignants ils voient de la
complexification dans l'apprentissage du
français et surtout un nivellement par
le bas les enfants en difficulté vont
d'abord devoir intégrer le nouveau
predica puis les anciens complément
d'objet direct et indirect c'est le choc
de simplification socialiste dans un
contexte où les familles fuient de plus
en plus dans le privé voire le secteur
indépendant
vous ne trouvez rien de mieux que de
tenter de battre en brèche le principe
constitutionnel de la liberté
d'enseignement dans votre loi égalité
citoyenneté une loi fourre-tout de fat
de législature
deux articles porter atteinte à la
liberté d'enseignement non seulement
parce qu'il voulait restreindre les
modalités d'ouverture des écoles mais
aussi mettre en péril les bonnes
conditions d'exercice de l'instruction à
domicile heureusement le conseil
constitutionnel a censuré ces
dispositions
comment mettrez-vous enfin l'école sur
de bons rails
madame la ministre je vous laisse
deviner le prédicat de ma question
la parole l'état madame najat vallaud
belkacem ministères éducation nationale
de l'enseignement supérieur et de la
recherche
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les députés monsieur le député
frédéric res
merci pour votre question je vous ai
entendu sur ces bandes de l'assemblée
nationale très souvent déploré le fait
que puisse se développer dans certains
territoires de notre pays
des enseignements contraire aux valeurs
de la république je vous ai entendu
déploré souvent le fait que sous
prétexte des ducs est autrement des
enfants on puisse les embrigader dans
telle ou telle religion alors j'ai
souhaité mieux contrôler l'ouverture des
écoles hors contrat et c'est ce que je
vous ai proposé dans le cadre de la loi
égalité citoyenneté
en quoi est-ce que cela consiste et cela
consistait à en finir avec le fait
accompli qui conduit aujourd'hui dans ce
pays de plus en plus d'établissements
qu'on ne contrôle pas ouvrez à ouvrir
leurs portes avec pour tous critères
d'acceptation le fait que celui qui
ouvre ces établissements soient
titulaires du baccalauréat et soient de
nationalité française
c'est tout ce que l'on contrôle
aujourd'hui cela signifie qu'il est plus
facile d'ouvrir un établissement
scolaire dans ce pays que d'ouvrir un
bar ou un tabac voilà la réalité à
laquelle j'ai souhaité mettre fin
parce qu'une fois qu'on est devant le
fait accompli et les maires de france le
savent bien eux qui réclamaient une
législation
c'est très difficile de faire fermer un
établissement qui pose de sérieux
problèmes sauf à aller devant la justice
ce qui prend des années je vous ai donc
proposé cet amendement mesdames et
messieurs les députés de l'opposition
nationale fidèle à votre double discours
et à votre hypocrisie légendaire vous
l'avez refusé
vous êtes opposé à cet amendement le
père est saisi le conseil de michel
bouffioux un multiple de loi n'a pas été
adopté je me regrette
et pour ce qui me concerne je
continuerai et vous pourrez aller merci
la parole